did unlawfully in its care to uh people
in uh care homes
during the covert pandemic it's
obviously going to be a huge focus
of the harvard inquiry that is due to
start later this year but in terms of
pmqs this has only just come out and as
i understand it kirsten were very keen
to lead on the issues around cost of
living and tax cuts all rises ahead of
the local elections next week i was out
and about in wolverhampton
yesterday talking to voters and it is
the one issue on everyone's minds
everyone is feeling the pinch people
talking to me about petrol going up food
costs going up
struggling to make ends meet one trade
is saying to me it was the worst he'd
seen it in 20 years in terms of the
squeeze
on his own income and the costs
pressured he is under so it's something
people really feel it's very immediate
uh there's local elections next week and
i'm sure that kierstama will press the
prime minister on a matter that he knows
matters to voters and and we'll hope i
guess to get a set of responses from the
prime minister on on that topic just
just rounding off the high court ruling
very quickly um clearly we have got a
statement from the nhs we've heard from
matt hancock spokesperson of course who
you spoke to just just uh last week but
we haven't heard from the government yet
so the prime minister presumably will
have had to come up with some level of
response on that issue well i'm sure
that someone will ask him in the chamber
about the ruling and i'm sure he will
have a response and i would imagine
knowing how they handle these sorts of
things he will refer it
to the inquiry as you said matt hancock
in an interview with me last week when i
said to him was it a mistake to
discharge people from hospital into care
homes he said no it wasn't and he had a
series of other reasons
that he gave for that which you can
watch that interview on on youtube you
can find the link
that was from last week but the high
court said uh that that despite a grown
awareness of asymptomatic transmissions
through march 2020 there was no evidence
uh that that was raised or addressed so
the government knew that the
asymptomatic transmissions was happening
but they didn't actually affect policies
quick enough to best protect people in
care homes and the result was that many
people died that perhaps didn't need to
and that is a
sore on people's hearts that lost loved
ones uh that cannot be erased and it
will be i'm sure a huge issue in this
upcoming inquiry into the lessons from
the pandemic beth thank you let's uh go
to the commons pmq's begins of this
session i wanted to remind the house of
what we have achieved more than 20 acts
of parliament have been passed including
our national insurance act will increase
the thresholds from july and be worth an
average of 330 pounds a year the largest
single personal tax cut for a decade and
our economic crime act to respond to
putin's illegal war in ukraine and we
hope by the end of the session to have
passed our borders bill to take control
of our immigration system our
police bill to make our streets safer
our health bill to reduce bureaucracy
and help cut the cobid backlogs only
today new figures show that we have
already recruited over 13 500 additional
police since 2019 well ahead well ahead
of our 12 000 target those police are
already on your streets making your
community safer we're focusing on
delivering the people's priorities and
there is plenty more to come in the
queen's beach on the 10th of may
mr speaker this morning i had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today
mr speaker as a proud maritime nation
the united kingdom has long relied on
its coastal communities to help deliver
national prosperity but today too many
of them face shared challenges and
disproportionately high levels of
deprivation does my right honourable fan
therefore agree with me that to ensure
beautiful constituencies like mine in
hastings and rye can properly unleash
their full potential a specific and
targeted government strategy focusing on
communities on coastal communities as
needed and will he meet with me to
discuss this yes
yes indeed mr speaker and if she looks
at the leveling up white paper she will
find
that it is indeed directed clearly at uh
uh enhancing and improving the lives of
in our coastal uh communities tilting
resource and attention uh towards those
fantastic coastal communities and i will
make sure that she gets a meeting with
the relevant minister as soon as
possible now comes the leader of the
opposition
uh thank you mr speaker i know the prime
minister will have whipped his
backbenchers to scream and shout
and that's fine
that's fine
but i hope i hope he's also sent a clear
message that there's no place for sexism
and misogyny
or looking down on people because of
where they come from in his party
in this house
or in modern britain
next year mr speaker the uk is set
for the slowest growth and the highest
inflation in the g7
why is he failing to manage the economy
mr speaker well let me first of all say
uh in response to what the uh rhino
gentleman said about sexism and misogyny
that i uh exchanged uh messages with the
right honourable lady over the weekend
and i i repeat what i said to her there
could be absolutely no place uh for such
uh behavior or such
expression in this house and we should
treat each other mr speaker frankly uh
with the respect uh that each other
deserves and on on his point about uh
the uh the economy yes of course it is
true that there is a uh a crisis of
global inflation uh around the around
the world uh but this government is is
tackling it uh with all sorts of uh with
all sorts of ways that you would expect
mr speaker helping people with the cost
of their of their energy a british
energy uh a far more by the way than the
labor will put in a british energy
security strategy to undo the mistakes
of previous labour government speaker
but but above all above all making sure
making sure that we have the fastest
growth in the g7 last year which would
not have been possible if we listened if
we listened to him and and if we
listened to him we would have frankly
never come out of lockdown right mr
speaker
in july in july in july last year
and never forget mr speaker that no
labour government has left office with
unemployment lower than when they came
mr speaker he sounds like the copical
alley of the cost of living crisis
he pretends the economy is booming
the weather problems they're global
but in the real world our growth is set
to be slower than every g20 country
except one
russia and our inflation our inflation
is going to be double the rest of the g7
does he think that denying the facts
staring him in the face
makes things better
or worse for working people
[Applause]
mr speaker the facts are as the imf has
said that the uk came out of coded uh
faster than anybody else that's where we
had the fastest growth in the g7 last
year that would not have happened mr
speaker if we listened
to captain hindsight and his and if he
studies if he studies their forecast we
will return uh to being the fastest uh
by 2024 and the fastest in 2025 mr
speaker and that's what the ims forecast
say he asked about
let's read it he asks about working
people mr speaker this is the government
this is the party that supports working
people
unlike them with the biggest increase
with the biggest increase
yes yes i'll tell you what's going up
the living wage is going up mr speaker
by record amount
employment is going up mr speaker
by recorder max 500 000 more people
they don't want to hear let me just
let me give them the figures
500 000 more people in paid employment
now than there were before the pandemic
began and youth unemployment youth
unemployment at or near record lows
under labour just remind you everybody
under labour youth unemployment rose by
45 percent
[Applause]
mr speaker
this must be the oxford union debating
skills we've been hearing so much about
failing to answer the question
rambling incoherently throwing in
garbled metaphors powerful stuff prime
minister
here's the problem
it's not just his words that are
complacent it's his actions as well
the cost of living crisis was blindingly
obvious months ago
but he said worries about inflation were
unfounded
and he backed a tax hiking budget
does he think
that his choice
to be the only leader in the g7 to raise
taxes during the cost of living crisis
has made things better or worse for
working people
mr speaker as i've just explained to the
house and i'll repeat it uh once more
this government and our chancellor cut
taxes on
working people
the national insurance contribution uh
went down uh mr speaker by an average of
330 pounds but if he's if he's talking
about if he's talking about the health
and care levy maybe he's talking maybe
that's what he's he's droning on about
look at the health and care levee mrs
digger that is what is enabling us to
pay for 50 000 more nurses to pay for
clearing the cobia backlogs how tragic
how pitiful how pitiful that the party
of bevan should now be opposed to that
investment in the nhs mr smith
mr speaker
he's an ostrich
perfectly happy keeping his head in the
sand
working people are worried about paying
their bills
they're spending less and cutting back
that's bad for business and bad for
growth
working people are looking for help but
this week millions will look at their
pay slip and see a tax rise with his
fingerprints all over it
does he think that his 15th tax rise
has made things better or worse for
working people
[Applause]
mr speaker what we're doing for for
working people is not only lifting the
living wage by the by the record amount
uh helping people on universal credit
within a thousand pound tax cut mr
speaker but also cutting uh national
insurance uh contributions lifting the
threshold so that on average people pay
330 pounds less mr speaker but what
we're also doing is taking our country
and our economy forward investing in our
nhs which is a priority for the people
of this country unlike for the labor
party mr speaker but also ensuring that
we have record creation of jobs mr
speaker and that is what matters high
wage high skill jobs half a million more
they don't care about jobs we go we do
we do
we believe in high wage high skilled
jobs and that's the answer for the
economy
[Applause]
mr speaker it's as if he's only just
waking up to the cost of living crisis
and his big idea
fewer mots
it actually makes the cones hotline
sound visionary and inspirational
north sea oil producers are making so
much unexpected profit they call
themselves a cash machine
that cash could be used to keep energy
bills down
instead he chooses he chooses
to protect their profits
that household bills rocket and slap
taxes on working people who are earning
a living yeah does he think that that
choice
has made things better or worse for
working people
what we're doing is making things better
for working people than his plans would
do by a mile mr speaker
we're raising more we're putting more to
support people is that with their energy
costs uh than he would with his new tax
on on business uh 9.1 billion pounds uh
that we're putting in an immediate 150
pound cut in people's council tax uh
their thing only raises 6.6 billion and
what it does what it does is it clobbers
the very businesses that we need to
invest in energy to bring that to bring
the prices down for people across this
country clean green energy the wind
farms the hydrogen that this country
needs and what this government is also
doing mr speaker is reversing the tragic
historic mistake of the labour party in
refusing to invest in nuclear we're
going to have we're going to have a
nuclear a nuclear reactor every year and
not a nuclear reactor every decade which
is what we got under labour
[Applause]
so they're the party of excess oil and
gas profits and we're the party of
working people
this tory government's had its head in
the sand throughout the cost of living
crisis
first they let prices get out of control
then they denied it was happening
they failed to do anything about it and
then they made it worse with higher
taxes
because of his choices we are set to
have the slowest growth and the highest
inflation in the g7
mr speaker a vote for labor next week is
a vote for a very different set of
countries
we would ask oil and gas companies to
pay their fair share and reduce energy
costs
we wouldn't hammer working people with
the worst possible tax at the worst
possible time
we'd insulate bills
to get the henchmen homes to get bills
down
and we've closed the tax avoidance
schemes that have helped his chancellor
where is he
reduce his family's tax bill while
putting everyone else's up that's a
proper plan for the economy so why
doesn't he get on with it and finally
make choices that make things better not
worse for working people
mr speaker i can tell the right origin i
listened over many weeks so many years
uh this guy is doomed to be a permanent
spectator mr speaker
they have
they have no we have a plan to fix the
nhs and fix social care they have no
plan we have a plan to fix our borders
with our deal with rwanda they have no
plan we have a plan to take our economy
forward they have no plans let me tell
you something he talks about the
elections he talks about the elections
in a few days time mr speaker let me let
me let me remind him that everywhere you
look at labour administration it is a
bankrupt shambles
hammersmith hammersmith council spent
20s labor run hammersmith spent 27 000
pounds on eu flags mr speaker
after the referendum labor run
nottingham council bankrupt because of
their investment in some communist
energy plan of the kind that that he now
favors and you should apologize for it
labour run croydon bankrupt mr speaker
because their dodgy property deals i
know never forget never forget labor run
britain in 2010 bankrupt because of what
the labour government did and they said
they said they had no money left mr
speaker he he looks at council attacks
look at the difference between he loves
to he basically lives in islington or
candle or somewhere like that
he should
contrast contrast neighboring
westminster which has the lowest council
tax in the country and better services
too that's the difference between labor
and conservative across the country mr
speaker vote conservative on the 5th of
may
[Applause]
would the prime minister join me
in welcoming the huge step forward in
the regeneration of hyena town center in
my constituency by the successful
purchase of the rundown old grammar
school building using the government's
town's fund money this week and what do
you agree that's exactly the sort of
local delivery people should be voting
on in next week's local elections
[Applause]
i hear my honourable friend is entirely
right and that is those are the issues
on which uh people are going to be
voting and as i said they're going to be
voting for better value uh for uh better
services and lower council taxes and i
hope they'll be voting conservative
no club the leader of the smp in
blackfoot
thank you mr speaker can i associate
myself with the remarks of the leader of
the opposition and the absolutely
disgusting misogyny and sexism that was
witnessed by the uh deputy leader of the
labour party that should shame us all
what has happened over the last few days
mr speaker this morning the trussell
trust confirmed that 830 000 children
across the uk
are being left to depend
on emergency food parcels
so instead of converting a tory talking
shop at cabinet the prime minister
should be acting to help those children
and help families through the cost of
living emergency if he is genuinely
looking for ideas to tackle this tory
made crisis he'd be wiser to look beyond
his cabinet colleagues who of course
know that he won't be there for very
much longer so
as a parting gift
here's an idea for the prime minister
the scottish government has introduced
and now doubled
the game-changing scottish child payment
of at least 1040 pounds a year helping
those families who are being the hardest
hit
is the prime minister
prepared to match this payment across
the uk
to help families through this emergency
mr speaker what we're doing to help
families and
of course it's important to uh to do
everything we can to help families in in
in a tough time that's why uh we've
massively increased the funds available
to local councils to support families
that are having uh uh a particular
hardship uh the the holidays and
activities fun now running at 200
million pounds is is there as well we
will do everything we can to support uh
families throughout the uh this period
when we're dealing with the aftershocks
of the covet uh pandemic mr speaker but
if i if i may say so i think this is
another example uh and you may not
appreciate me pointing this out but it
is true there's another example of the
vital strength of our economic union and
the importance and the importance of
support from the uk treasury which is uh
which is what he gets
here
my goodness mr speaker we have children
facing poverty the scottish government
are responding by the child payment and
by the way it will increase again later
this year and we get nothing we get
nothing but empty words from the prime
minister it was plenty of desperate
pre-election waffle that we heard
earlier but i'll take it as i know there
is no support for hard-pressed families
it is clear by the day that the prime
minister's supposed plan to fight the
tory made cost of living crisis is not
only non-fiscal it's non-existent so
prime minister i'll try again
here are three other ideas for the prime
minister that would help families with
soaring costs right now scrap his
national insurance tax site reverse the
tory cuts to universal credit and match
scotland's six percent benefits rise
instead of imposing a real term cut
three things that will make a difference
to millions of people has the prime
minister come to terms with the reality
that if he fails to act now the voters
will send him and his sleaze-ridden
party a message by voting snp next
thursday
[Applause]
mr speaker we're helping families up and
down the country with the universal
credit uh take the ask about universal
credit uh we're tapering it so that uh
people get a
another thousand pounds in their pockets
working people get another thousand
pounds uh in their pockets we're helping
families in the way that i that i have
described uh mr speaker and just to
remind the house that under this
government there are now far fewer
children in working and work less in
workplace households than there were uh
before this government came in and that
is because we believe in championing
work champion employment and helping
people into high-wage high-skilled jobs
that's what canton as for our respective
political longevities well i wouldn't
like to bet on him on that's outlasting
me mr speaker
oral forest
thank you mr speaker
last april the berkshire west camp
service received an additional 120
million to tackle
waiting times for autism and adhd
diagnoses
12 months on they have outlined a
general ambition to reduce delays but
have set no targets or timescales for
improvement with some families still
waiting two years for their child to be
seen
does my right honourable friend agree
that when significant investment of
public money is made people have the
right to know how and when services will
be improved
and would he support my campaign for a
12-month maximum weight for any family
in west berkshire seeking a diagnosis of
this kind yeah
she she's absolutely right and she's uh
it's a great campaign that she's uh
she's running uh mr speaker and the
government is indeed providing the the
funding uh to improve uh autism and
learning disability services uh but it's
also important that people get the
diagnosis that they uh the assessment
that they need uh within uh within 12
weeks and uh the measures in our health
and care bill uh will approve local
accountability for those services so
jeffrey donaldson thank you mr speaker
the rhode haulage association has uh uh
confirmed that the cost of moving goods
from this part of the united kingdom to
northern ireland has risen by 27 in the
first year of the operation of the
protocol the irish sea border is harming
our economy it is undermining political
stability in northern ireland next week
the people of northern ireland will go
to the polls to elect an assembly what
hope can the prime minister give to the
people of northern ireland that this
protocol will be removed and that
northern ireland's place within the uk
internal market will be restored
[Music]
i thank him very much and i think that
what the whole house will want to uh to
support is the the balance and symmetry
of the good friday agreement that's what
really matters that's a great legacy for
all of us and uh it's vital that the
protocol
or the arrangements we have in northern
ireland uh should command the support of
all sides and that's what this
government uh will uh undertake to uh
ensure
ben bradlee yeah thank you mr speaker
i'm grateful to the prime minister for
the additional funding and support that
mansfield has received over recent years
for education and skills for tackling
crime and for our town centers we'll be
bidding into the leveling up fund as
well this spring
mansfield residents now want to see the
tangible outcomes of those capital funds
for the town centre so come on right up
a friend look seriously at how we might
help accelerate the process after
lengthy process of getting from
successful funding announcement to
spades in the ground so that my
residents can benefit from those
investments
uh my my honorable friend is a fantastic
champion for uh for mansfield and and
indeed a wider area uh and i i i i'm
delighted that the mansfield was awarded
12 million pounds as part of the towns
uh fund uh i can't endorse any specific
uh project but the next round is coming
up shortly and we'll be in that well
coming up shortly we'll be i will be
announced in the autumn caroline lucas
thank you very much mr speaker
56 members of this house are under
investigation for sexual misconduct and
that includes three of his cabinet
ministers the prime minister has just
rightly said that there can be no place
for sexism and misogyny in this house
so can he now confirm whether he
considers that sexual harassment
apparently unlike bullying and lying is
grounds for dismissal under the
ministerial code yeah yeah
thank
you mr speaker and of course uh sexual
harassment is uh is intolerable and
it's quite right that uh members should
now have a procedure by which they can
bring that to the attention of the of
the house authorities and i i think
that's a that's a that's a good thing uh
and of course it's grounds for re for
dismissal
thank you mr speaker financial scams
have grown dramatically in recent years
and are now the most common form of
crime harming millions of families every
year most of them are enabled by online
platforms such as facebook and google
that make vast profits from advertising
fraudsters does my right honourable
friend the prime minister agree with me
those companies that profit from
promoting fraud should help pay the cost
of fraud and that online platform should
compensate victims that they helped
create and will he work with me to
achieve that end yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
look i have to say mr speaker to my to
my honourable friend who i know uh
for many years i think this is typical
of his creativity we are going to uh
look at exactly how we could uh make
that uh kind of uh that kind of measure
work
i think it's important that we proceed
with care and and get it right and i and
i'm going to make sure that he has a a
meeting with the relevant minister in
dcms as fast as possible thank you
falstrom you mr speaker
hundreds and thousands of people are
still shielding they're living in fear
of covid as they know the vaccine hasn't
mounted an antibody response for them
and they remain at increased risk of
serious illness or death
there is hope though ever sheld which
gives immuno-compromised people 83
protection for six months
sadly the government hasn't ordered any
of this despite the mhra given approval
on the 17th of march
now i appreciate the prime minister
might not have all of the details to
hand so will he meet with me to talk
about this life-saving and life-changing
drug yeah
i thank her very much and i think she's
absolutely right to to speak up for
those who are who are shielding and who
and who are anxious and we're doing
everything we can to protect and and to
reassure them uh on ever shield
we are evaluating it at the moment but i
will make sure that she has a meeting as
soon as possible uh with with the
department of health
thank you mr speaker my conservative
council in kensington
500 pounds less council tax than
neighbouring camden labor
and
it has
four times
as many bin collections
you haven't misheard
500 pounds less four times as many years
does my right honorable friend agree
with me that everyone who wants low
council tax and good services needs to
vote conservatively
mr speaker do i do i agree with my
honorable friend
there is not a syllable with which any
sensible person in this country could
possibly dissent
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker uh the last week
that billy telegraph not normally a
paper that i read but i did read this
headline that said northern ireland
could be forced to follow eu rules and
covet tests the chancellor told the
house that northern ireland could
benefit from moves to scrap vap on
energy efficiency measures
because of the protocol
so neither protocols restrictions
threaten the shortage of covert tests in
northern ireland so can i ask the prime
minister the financial cost of the
protocol can be measured but the true
cost in relation to vat to medicines to
covert tests and damage relationships is
much much greater when is the government
and my prime minister going to restore
our prius in the united kingdom yeah
i thank you very much and there is
clearly
an economic cost
to the protocol and uh that is also now
turning into a political uh problem and
an imbalance in in sentiment about it we
need to rectify that balance for the
sake of the good friday agreement on
which uh this country uh depends
paul holmes thank you
yeah
yeah yeah by 2025 liberal democrat
easley borough council will have a debt
of 650 million pounds
which stands at six which stands at six
thousand three hundred pounds for every
resident in eastleigh does the prime
minister think that it is acceptable for
this council to become a speculative
property developer and what advice would
he give to my constituents next week to
put a stop to this casino council and
it's profitable
here my honorable friend is completely
right about uh about eastleigh barrow
council
debts they have they have run up and i
can't even see the leader of the liberty
democrats
in this place
not even not even delivering value for
money for his own constituents mr
speaker
mr speaker the cost of household food
bills is set to rise by
271 pounds this year as prices soar the
supermarkets are lowering their prices
to help customers struggling to buy food
and the resolution foundation have
reported that 1.3 million low-income
britons will be pushed into absolute
poverty by the cost of living crisis but
this government is doing nothing to
protect people who are struggling if the
supermarkets are stepping in to protect
people's pockets
what will the prime minister do yeah
uh what we've done is just in the last
uh a few months is put 22 billion pounds
in uh to help people with two minutes
bigger with the cost of living but i
want to i want to to to pay
tribute and to to the uh those
businesses which are now trying to
protect uh consumers from uh the impact
of the glo of the global inflation
crisis and the fact is that many many
businesses now do have the the cash
reserves not to take price as uh as they
put it uh but to shield consumers from
the impact and i i hope that they do so
that's right
mr speaker mr speaker i've recently been
contacted by my ukrainian counterpart
the chair of the ukrainian treasury
committee with some ideas as to how we
can further tighten the screw on the
russian economy particularly through the
international tax regime and i was of
course able to affirm the full support
of the ukrainian people from right
across this house
uh and also uh the uh gentleman
concerned of course knows the work that
my right honourable friend has done to
promote sanctions internationally but
would he consider meeting with me to
consider these uh new proposals that are
being brought forward so that we make
sure no stone is unturned in facing up
to putin's vile regime yeah yeah
i thank my my random offender for what
he has been doing and what his uh select
committee has been doing uh in this area
about tightening the screw on putin's uh
regime and uh i think that uh uk
companies have have already shown that
they uh think very carefully about uh
investments are doing business with
putin's russia we've put a ban as he
knows on all new outward investments in
uh russia mr speaker but i'm i'm very
happy to make sure that uh further ideas
uh from my vulnerable friend uh should
be uh transmitted to the government and
uh to have the the meeting as soon as
possible
jeff smith thank you mr speaker
last night we learned that the home
secretary put the member for wakefield
on an expert panel offering advice on
sexual exploitation
at the time he was under a police
investigation following him for
allegations he assaulted a minor for
which he's since been found guilty he
sat on this panel long after the
conservative party had received a
complaint from his victim
isn't the prime minister of shame this
party didn't take the victim seriously
and put someone who abused a minor in
such an important position and does he
wish to take the opportunity to
apologize to them
uh mr speaker i believe that the home
office has already made a statement
about it and if there's any uh further
comment to make uh
they will be making a statement
thank you mr speaker mr speaker newcast
underlying borough council has secured
millions of pounds government investment
yeah for our high street but we do have
a problem with persistent anti-social
behavior on the high street and so
therefore would my under friend the
prime minister welcome the recent
appointments of a new chief constable
for staffordshire a new borough
commander for newcastle and the fact
that newcastle will get its own
dedicated response unit and when he also
send out what further measures the
government is taking to combat crime and
anti-social behavior
i i thank my honorable friend who is a
an avid champion of his constituents and
uh he and
well well
uh and mr speaker uh i can tell him i
can tell him i think maybe he missed
what i i said earlier on uh but we're
now running at 13 000 13
576 more police on the streets of this
country as a result of the actions uh
taken by this government and tougher
sentences as well mr speaker opposed uh
by the party opposite
cracking down on drugs gangs mr speaker
when their that party is soft on drugs i
think the leader of the opposition said
he would decriminalize uh you didn't
want people who can't say drugs to face
faith prison sentences mr speaker i
think i heard him say that and of course
cracking down on cross-channel uh
migrant uh gangs mr speaker on people
who risk the lives of migrants in the in
the english channel we're cracking down
on them uh and as far as i know uh they
would scrap the agreement the economic
and migration partnership with rwanda mr
speaker we have a plan they don't learn
thank you very much mr speaker four and
a half million people pay for their gas
and electricity using a prepayment meter
yeah they already pay more for their
energy than direct debit customers and
the number of people who are
disconnecting themselves because they've
run out of money for the meter is
increasing
what is the prime minister going to do
to ensure that all of our constituents
have a right to light and to warp
mr speaker we are we're working with off
gem and the company all the companies to
ensure that
we protect people in this in this
difficult time but uh well what we're
also doing is making sure that we uh
support people uh not just with the cold
weather payments uh the winter fuel
payments uh but making sure that through
half a billion pounds more to councils
we look after people and this would be
that the types of people that the right
on the gentleman is referring to
who are finding it particularly tough uh
we will do everything we can to shield
the people of this country as we get
through the aftershocks of kobe and deal
with a global inflation problem
mr speaker within the last hour or so
it's been reported that some 287 members
of this house have been sanctioned by
the russian state now i'm sure nobody
here is rushing to change their summer
holiday plans but perhaps the prime
minister
will uh assure us that he will continue
his excellent relationship with
president zielenski and continue to
provide the ukrainian people and the
ukrainian military with the support
support that they need
well mr speaker i i it's no uh i think
no disrespect to those who haven't been
uh
uh when i when i say that all those 287
should regard it as a badge of honor
and uh what we what we what we will do
uh mr speaker is keep up our robust and
principled support for the ukrainian
people and their right to protect uh
their lives their families and to defend
their selves that that's what this
country is doing and that has the
overwhelming support uh i think of the
whole house
final question design
speaker
today a court has found that the
government acted unlawfully when its
policies led to the discharge of
untested patients from hospitals to care
homes at the start of the pandemic
the court also found no evidence that
the former health secretary addressed
the issue of the risk to care home
residents of such transmission despite
the government insisting at the time
that a protective ring had been thrown
around care homes
the government has once again been found
to have broken the law yep will the
prime minister
apologize to the families of the
thousands and thousands of people who
died in care homes in the first half of
2020 and will he also apologize to care
workers for the shameful comment that he
made in july 2020 when he said that too
many care homes didn't follow procedures
in the way that they could have
mr speaker of course i want to renew my
uh well my apologies and uh and
sympathies for all those who lost uh
loved ones uh during the pandemic uh
people who uh who lost loved ones in in
care homes uh and i want to remind the
house of how what an incredibly
difficult time that was and how
difficult that decision was and there
were there were very we didn't know very
much about the disease and the point i
was trying to make to which she refers
is the thing that we didn't know in
particular uh mr speaker uh was uh that
kovid could be transmitted
asymptomatically in in the way that it
was and uh and that was something that i
wish we had known more about uh at the
time as for the ruling that she mentions
uh we will study it and uh we will of
course uh respond further in due course
michael fabrican mr speaker as you've
just heard from my honorable friend the
member for milton keyne north
the interfax news agency under an hour
ago in moscow
announced that the foreign ministry of
the russian government will now sanction
287
members and former members of the house
of commons from both sides of this house
i'm proud to say mr speaker that both
you and i are on that list
so mr speaker are you able to give any
advice
to members of the house of commons
honorable and right honourable members
regarding this
normally i wouldn't but i think it is an
important matter and i'm grateful to the
honourable gentleman to let me know the
start of questions that he wanted to
catch my eye
although the issue is raised is not
strictly a point for it i am of course
alarmed to hear what is reported to the
chamber rather than give a knee-jerk
reaction now i'm sure the government
will rapidly be assessing the
implications of this move i am therefore
asking the government to keep me
and the house authorities briefed on
this very important issue and now she'll
make
and thereby sure that members are kept
informed as appropriate
sorry further to that point i'm very
grateful i'm absolutely distressed that
i'm not on the list mr speaker
and
and and if i'm honest slightly surprised
i can only assume
that the russian federation accepts that
every single thing that i have said
about president putin over the last few
years is true
he is a barbarous villain and we must
make sure that he fails
i'm sure you know me i've got yourself
for them
prime minister
prime minister's questions uh wrapping
up just a few questions to the speaker
in fact about the sanctioning by russian
authorities of 287 mps which crossed by
the interfax news agency about an hour
ago was how things were wrapping up but
before we discuss pmqs we wanted to hit
a couple of bits of breaking news that
have crossed in the last 40 minutes
first reaction to that high court ruling
which found the government acted
unlawfully releasing patients from
hospitals to care homes at the beginning
of the coveted pandemic we've got a
statement from charlie williams a
spokesperson for the covid19 bereave
families for justice group part of that
statement says for the thousands of
families like mine who lost loved ones
and care homes the last two years of
cover-ups and denials have been
unbelievably painful we've always known
that our loved ones were thrown to the
wolves by the government and the claims
by matt hancock that a protective ring
was made around care homes was a
sickening lie now a court has found
their decisions unlawful and it's clear
the decisions taken led to people dying
who may otherwise still
be with their loved ones today we now
need to see those responsible for those
dark days held accountable and lessons
learned to save lives ensuring the grim
scenes of spring 2020 are never repeated
uh that question that topic only came up
once towards the end of pmq's a question
from daisy cooper libdem
to the prime minister about the high
court judgment and the prime minister
actually reiterated somewhat the tone
from
matt hancock's statement earlier saying
we didn't know that covid could be
transmitted asymptomatically and they
wish they'd known it earlier he said
he'd study the court case now we had a
second bit of breaking news during pmq's
uh the office of conservative chief whip
chris heaton harris says he's in
investigating reports that a
conservative mp watched pornography on
his phone in the commons chamber a
statement from the conservative whips
office said the chief whip is looking
into this matter
this behavior is wholly unacceptable and
action will be taken uh beth rigby uh of
course uh is uh with me our political
editor we'll get to pmq's uh beth but uh
extraordinary bit of news crossing about
uh a front bench mp no less uh
apparently watching porn in the commons
chamber yeah this is uh this is quite a
shocking story um and it emerged in a
conversation between female mps
last night
and i've had it corroborated
by
an mp that was in that meeting
and apparently at that meeting a female
minister
said that uh an mp was watching
pornography next to her so the
supposition is it's a front front bench
but that hasn't been explicitly said
and a colleague in the room immediately
corroborated that
i was also told that this minister this
female minister
apparently also said that the culprit
had been doing this in committees so in
committee meetings that this had also
happened there so this
in terms of her evidence wasn't the
first occasion um
and i've also been told um the the
women that the two mps have subsequently
spoken to the chief whip uh chris heaton
harris and chris heaton-harris has made
a statement if i can find it
he has said so i'm just trying to find
it
the chief whip is looking into this
matter this behavior is wholly
unacceptable so apparently the mps have
named
this person to the chief whip and
they're now looking into it the prime
minister has said
in the comments just then that sexual
harassment is grounds for dismissal
let's see what comes of that but i
should also say in the round of all of
this uh caroline wheeler the political
editor of the sunday times uh had an
exclusive story on sunday saying that
over 50 mps were being investigated for
sexual
harassment so a truly shocking story uh
and i think it will have some way to run
and i think everyone was was pretty
amazed that um female mps are sharing
uh stories and experiences like that in
the in their place of work
absolutely and uh the question as you as
you mentioned that led the prime
minister to say that of course sexual
harassment is is grounds for domestic
dismissal came from a question from
caroline lucas
about sexual harassment and no doubt had
this story crossed about uh supposedly a
tory mp watching porn in the house
before pmq's no doubt that would have
been incorporated as well as you said
the chief whip crease chris heaton
harris said that action
will be taken um let's pivot uh beth two
pmqs and you were absolutely right uh
beforehand when we listed all these
extraordinary talking points uh today
from russian ukraine to that uh high
court uh ruling to partygate but all of
the questions from the opposition leader
kirstjalmer were about the cost of
living christ exactly this is an
opposition leader that at this moment 10
days out from actually less than that a
week out from local elections where
4
350 or more
council seats in england being contested
a number of different councils
he is very much focused on speaking to
voters and using pmqs to try and press
home the point of criticizing boris
johnson not just over the cost of living
crisis but also actually in that pmq's
criticizing him over his handling of the
economy you know uh that for for ever
more really that the conservatives will
always be the party more trusted on the
economy it's an area of weakness for
labour labor traditionally always being
the party strong on the nhs but kirsten
were really criticizing the prime
minister also raising something that the
prime minister said to us back in
october actually when the cost of living
crisis and fears over inflation began to
really build in an interview with me he
said those fears over inflation were
unfounded and cuts kirsten they're using
the prime minister's words and turning
it back on him saying you're an ostrich
he said you've he called the prime
minister an ostrich keeping his head in
the sand on the cost of living naming 50
15 tax rises uh the prime minister
responded saying we have a plan for the
nhs we've had to raise taxes for social
care
but it's a difficult period for the
prime minister because the cost of
living crisis is real and it's really
hard in voters you referenced that being
an absolute key part of pmq's and uh we
can listen to that now that exchange on
the cost of living crisis between uh
secure stamina and the prime minister
brothers
he's an ostrich
perfectly happy keeping his head in the
sand
working people are worried about paying
their bills
they're spending less and cutting back
that's bad for business and bad for
growth working people are looking for
help but this week
millions will look at their pay slip and
see a tax rise with his fingerprints all
over it
does he think that his 15th tax rise
has made things better or worse for
working people
[Applause]
mr speaker what we're doing for for
working people is not only lifting the
living wage by the by the record amount
uh helping people on universal credit
within a thousand pound tax cut mr
speaker but also cutting uh national
insurance contributions lifting the
threshold so that on average people pay
330 pounds less mr speaker but what
we're also doing is taking our country
and our economy forward investing in our
nhs which is a priority for the people
of this country unlike for the labour
party mr speaker but also ensuring that
we have record creation of jobs mr
speaker and that is what matters high
wage high skill jobs half a million more
they don't care about jobs it's bigger
we do
we do
we believe in high wage high skilled
jobs and that's the answer for the
economy
well the prime minister there very very
um enthused wasn't he impassionate about
his arguments look they clearly know
it's a huge problem it was a massive
discussion in cabinet yesterday the cost
of living that all leaked because the
government wanted to be known to the
public that they're looking at different
things dominic raab on sky news uh this
morning talking about how to help with
uh the cost of living and housing costs
has been talked about whether or not to
to lessen the number of get get an mo2
every other year as opposed to every
year cost talk about scrapping green
taxes reducing housing costs lots of
ideas from the government about how to
tackle the cost of living because they
know
inflation could run to 11.8 per cent in
the autumn and that is hurting people
it's definitely gonna get worse before
it gets better the question is how long
it belongs interesting that the prime
minister kept pointing to that fact the
fastest growth in the g7 last year
that's true but from a low base and
kyocera pointing to imf forecast for the
slowest growth in the g7 yeah next year
and the question i think next week will
be how much people are already feeling
that uh this year beth the other
question i just want to touch on are we
surprised i know you were right that
everything was going to be on cost of
living but surprised that we got through
a whole pmq's not a single question on
partygate at all well i think
for kierstarma he has to tread a fine
line here
the partygate issue is clearly damaging
the prime minister you can see it in the
polling but if he keeps going on about
it does he begin to alienate voters
where it seems like a very political
attack i have to say when i was out on
the road yesterday of course everyone
was most worried about cost of living
but it did come up it does matter to
people and they are irritated by it also
wasn't a huge amount on russia and
ukraine apart from that exchange towards
the end about mps uh being sanctioned
beth rigby as always thank